[Music]
today is the two year anniversary of my
field suicide attempt
[Music]
this is hard um
for for the last couple years i have
been in a hole that seems insurmountable
and though i may not show it it is
slowly engulfing me
after a decade in the military i figure
out it's a joke and i don't want to be a
part about it anymore
we good all right
my secret is not so well kept as there's
other people in my
predicament i served 12 years in prison
and been a victim of the mental health
system not being effective enough and
helping people but
aside from that all systems go living
life at 100.
why so serious
i genuinely believe in my heart
that my mom's love for me is completely
conditional
on whether or not i become successful
in in my career or in my school and that
and that if i don't do well
um i know i feel like she
won't love me and she won't care about
me and
and to be honest like she's she said
some things that and she's done some
things
where i've really needed her help and
she definitely wasn't there for me
so i probably i have my secrets i have
deep seated trust issues
against my mom but even though i tell
her i love her every day
[Music]
i have been in love with my best friend
who is a female for the past four years
and nobody
will ever know that because i'm not
ready for anybody to do that
[Music]
my my secret is
um food is
a very big challenge for me um
i'm struggling with it and it go along
with body image
so i'm 49 years old
and my secret is that
i struggle with vanity and so as a 49
year old woman
who's definitely not getting younger i
deal with aging or actually i don't deal
with it at all and it actually holds me
back
when you've grown up your whole life
with the expectation of
always looking good and being in shape
and being thin
and being the best that you can be
when beauty fades one day they don't
tell you that that beauty fades
to my surprise i am going to turn 50
this year and my beauty is fading
and sorry
so um i have let the aging hold me back
from so many things in just the last
probably five years i threw out all my
bathing suits
most of my shorts basically i stopped
really wanting to socialize
because i look older i've gained weight
and i didn't think that i would be
accepted anymore because
my beauty has faded and um
that kind of it kind of changed one day
when i was hanging out with my
16 year old daughters her and her
friends
it was just the simplest word that words
that she said to me but it's really like
changed me in the past couple weeks and
she just looked at me and she
because i had explained to her that i
don't wear bathing suits and i just
don't feel beautiful anymore because i'm
getting older and
she just looked at me and she said
embrace it
there's nothing you can do about it so
just embrace it
you're beautiful the way that you are
and so i just want to get that out to
anybody that's struggling with that you
know just get rid of that vanity get rid
of that insecurity and just
embrace who you are those changes
thank you
[Music]
i come from a conservative household and
it's really religious
and i've grown up in that faith but
recently since i've moved out i just
wish my parents and my friends who are
also religious could realize that i'm
trying to find
a relationship with my faith on my own
and that doesn't mean that i will
follow all the rules so like i'll follow
what i can but it's my life
and my connection with faith that i'm
trying to figure out on my own and i
wish they would just let me do that
without criticizing me and telling me
what to do
when i was little i used to lie
and make up stories about who my
biological father actually was
because i was ashamed of who he is
[Music]
my dad isn't really in my life and i
always joke about how like that's fun
because it's like fun to be a girl with
daddy issues
i really wish i made more of an effort
to contact him
because i'm sure he wants to talk to me
i guess that's my secret
when my brother died i wanted to die
with him too
[Music]
i self-harmed for the first time since
yesterday since eighth grade and the
only thing that's keeping me going is
imagining retiring in new zealand or
austria or somewhere else
but i think it turned out okay
um i guess my secret is i'm very selfish
and a lot of people that meet me don't
think i am
but it's something that i struggle with
every day and i try to change it
[Music]
my secret is that after being single for
two and a half years i'm not really sure
that i want to have sex anyone
with anyone for a while because i
just don't want to get intimate with
anyone it's just
too much of a pain in my ass
and i don't have a lot of trust for
people at this point anymore
when i was poor i used to steal from
groceries
whenever the opportunity presented
itself i wasn't
an aggressive thief it was more like oh
i left the water jug
at the bottom of the grocery cart and
they didn't notice and i didn't tell
them about it
i did not if anything
just more embarrassed that i was poor i
will remain anonymous
[Music]
i find all people attractive and i don't
think
that love should be confined
[Music]
so i have quarantined myself away from
everybody
except strangers on dating apps
when i was five years old my mother
called
the fire department because we had a
television that exploded
and she never knew this but i actually
urinated
in the back of the tv to see what would
happen what
possessed me to do that i do not know so
about a year ago
i went to a party with me and my friends
and we all decided
how funny would it be if i got an ass
tattoo i was like
what what should i get and and as my
friend was very drunk
and if you would like to see the tattoo
i can
and so he had me bent over
a hot tub and he kept poking my
my ass with a stick and poke so you can
get a tattoo
that says [ __ ] happens on my butt
and that's all
[Music]
oh i should probably have a sip of this
first
because my secret is that there's a
little bit of tequila in this here
seltzer
[Music]
he looks sexier with new clothes
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys doria here just want to let you
guys know that to be safe i do have a
mark on the ground
so people are far enough from the mic
not to touch it also
after every single person goes i make
sure to clean the mic love you guys
i hope you're staying safe make sure to
subscribe
if you want if not it's all good no hard
feelings
all right bye